Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul today.
This is just a quick video to talk about
an interesting linguistic phenomenon,
something that might come up in some of
my videos in the future and that is the
topic of language isolates.
Often when I talk about languages,
I talk about the family that language
belongs to and how it's related to other
languages in that family.
For example,
Hebrew and Arabic are sister languages
of the Semitic language family,
French and Italian are sister languages
of the romance language family,
but did you know that there are some
languages that have no family
whatsoever.
Those are called language isolates.
A language isolate as far as we know,
has no genetic relationship with any
other language.
That means that it does not descend from
the same ancestor language as any other
language that we know of.
They are basically a language family
with only one member.
Some commonly known language isolates
are the Basque language which is spoken
in parts of France and Spain.
Also the new language which is spoken in
Hokkaido and northern Japan.
Some people say Korean,
although that one is disputed and also
some native American languages as well
as some languages on the island of New
Guinea.
New Guinea happens to be the most
linguistically diverse place on the
planet.
If you want to know more about it,
check out this video right here.
Why are there language isolates?
Well,
one possible reason is that that
language used to belong to a family that
had numerous languages in it,
but that one particular language became
dominant and replaced all of the others
or maybe all the other languages in that
family were replaced by a different
language.
For example,
a language of a conquering army,
but one particular group refused to give
up and their language became a language
isolate.
It is possible for a new language
isolate to arise if that community of
people is completely separated,
completely isolated from other
languages.
That's because children have the ability
to spontaneously create new language in
these modern times.
That happens most often with sign
languages.
There have been numerous cases around
the world of children in deaf schools
spontaneously creating new sign
languages that are completely unrelated
to any others.
In the world,
some linguists say that if you took a
group of infants and you raised them in
an environment with no language,
that they would spontaneously create
their own language isolate.
This is just a quick video to introduce
that linguistic concept that some people
have been talking about in response to
some of my videos in particular,
the one about Japanese and Korean.
If you have any comments about this
topic,
leave them down below,
but stay tuned for another feature video
coming soon.
Thank you for watching.
Have a nice.